[Music]
Space Jam stretch
reach across the table slap cheer in the
face
[Music]
welcome back to another phenomenal
episode of scored stories where today we
have Mr Tim Chang terong soon
compelling tale featuring brilliant
music by our in-house Rye anime wow hey
hi everyone
the challenges I'll collaborate with you
afterwards all right this is your life I
don't want to ruin the video
I might add a little bit of oh oh but
like no no I'm not gonna bless it I'm
not gonna bless you I'm not gonna bless
it all right
this is a story
a violence oh I like silence
and Canada doesn't make sense I know
and Canada so what we've all done can I
compute these uh Asian shows meet and
greets
[Music]
um performances yeah things like that
celebration one time celebration
Invasion
intimidation
anticipation
so a wrongful shoot or some [__] I just
got done doing a performance in Calgary
Alberta
I take that back this was in Winnipeg
nice
Winnipeg Canada
after the show
it was me
Chia my wife my girlfriend at the time
we were eating at a late night Chinese
food spot with the promoters of the show
okay
um it was me Chia singer Erica David
and everybody that was a part of this
promoter company it was all the ladies
it was me and a bunch of ladies okay
late night Chinese Food Spot by Andrew
Garcia Andrew Garcia was not there okay
she said ladies I don't know just just
not ladyboys but he's he's the honorary
Asian in the whole Asia yes but he's not
an honorary lady
so we're chilling eating Chinese food
it was late having a good time
then
these drunk people walk into the
restaurant they walk by
it's a drunk Asian girl and a very Burly
Filipino man they see me they're big
fans they come in they're like yo we
love your [__] can we get some pictures
I'm like of course of course taking
pictures drunk Asian girl
drunk Filipino guy it's all love
then
a couple seconds later the Filipino boys
drunk
possibly Middle Eastern possibly Latina
girlfriend comes walking into the
restaurant
she's like what the [__] why are you
taking pictures who is this who are you
who is this why are you taking pictures
with him what is this the Filipino
dude's like yo
chill
relax
just relax yeah putang in a [__]
too loud he's like sorry about it sorry
so I'm like it's cool it's cool it's
cool but she's very obnoxious everybody
I'm eating food with they're like what's
wrong with this what's wrong with her
what's going on but you know everyone's
keeping it cool right
so then she's kind of like
she's kind of like
why are you taking like who is he she
doesn't like that you have attention
yeah she's like who who is he she's like
and then somebody at my table goes
who are you
oh and then she starts getting angry
she's like
excuse me
you don't know who I am
who are you so [__] Chia who is who
my girlfriend is getting very irritated
under her breath she goes
we don't want to know where you are
this [__] gets crazy
excuse me
you don't know who I am you don't oh you
know oh okay
I don't know so the Filipino dude is
like relax relax but then
he's having trouble keeping his chick
together right
she knows that she has said this [__]
all of a sudden
[Music]
I feel like this [__]
for fud Space Jam stretch reach across
the table slap cheer in the face
yes bro Chia gets how close was she I
thought she was it was one of these big
Asian tables bro with the [__]
spinning thing in the middle I have no
idea how dude was she sitting with you
guys no she was standing up reach across
the table slaps cheers oh no she's
shocked she is not a fighter she might
talk that [__] but she is not a fighter
no she didn't get slapped but you gotta
defend her honor now what does she say
so now Erica David takes Chia into the
bathroom she is in the bathroom this
[__] Filipino dude who went from
being my fan
now he knows his girl feels disrespected
he starts wilding out too he goes
tries to pick our table up tries to live
I'm like relax the soup is spilling
everywhere the soup gets on chia's phone
I'm like yo so now I feel like I need to
stand up because shit's getting crazy
I'm not a fighter but I'm like yo what
the [__] this Filipino dude he's messing
up girl's hair he's trying to toss our
table and I'm like
I ain't no [__] but I'm like this man
is gonna kill me
he's a big he's like a funky and he
looks like a Filipino Snorlax dude but
I'm like all right I stand up I'm like
yo what the [__] chill out
I'm ready to get beaten up but I'm
looking across the restaurant I'm like
I'm gonna break this Heineken bottle on
this man's face I'm gonna hit him with a
chair I'm gonna kick him in the dick I'm
gonna do whatever it takes but I think
when I stood up he was like oh all right
he's real because as soon as I stood up
he was like
I respect you
I respect you he starts to walk out
takes his chick with him oh my God thank
God
she comes out
she's trying she's trying she's trying
to get it together where it's scooping
soup
she's like
let's just get it to go let's just get
it to go
we go back to the hotel
she's still kind of like shooking about
his [__] right we're crying I'm like I'm
gonna make a joke to make it better I'm
like you want me to like go down on you
or something make you feel better
she's like
[Applause]
[Music]
you see my [__]
oh man holy [__] [__] crazy
crazy [__] years later um because Danny
real is from Winnipeg right yeah because
in between time she hit me up she's like
did you get into a [__] fight and win
a pig I was like almost right so we're
in Winnipeg doing Club event with Danny
Rayo and then
um she's like hey come here I want you
to meet somebody I [__] go to our
table our section it's the [__]
Filipino guy
apparently Danny dated him for a little
bit in Winnipeg why is he dating all
this women and women oh bro I don't know
I said that Adam he's like oh I'm like
what's up bro you [__] dancing up
he's like hey man
that girl was a [__] I'm sorry he's
like that's my ex now I'm sorry I
apologize for that night I'm like oh man
we good we good yeah you got to forgive
him man I I understand yo those kind of
girls are the those kind of girls are
the girls that can [__] get guys
killed yes
never the dudes yeah 100 yeah it's like
you're gonna let them do that [__] to me
yeah that is a walking liability bro
yeah yeah
I like when she kept saying you don't
know who I am yeah that's good like
she's the [__] how many followers do
you have [__] of course no one knows
what the [__] you are like she was the
[__] Persian princess of Winnipeg or
something oh she's Persian I don't know
what she was he was some type of
brunette ethnic yeah
what if she
is she might be
jerk I'm sorry you probably have way
more followers she's not Drake's sister
Jake has a sister that's Mexican you
never know that's crazy dude it was
crazy it was came out of nowhere like
every like it went from zero 100 all of
a sudden it was like she was saying
excuse me to [__] cheer getting
slapped and was like oh do you think
it's okay to beat her up if she hits
your woman yeah I think so uh I think
it's okay to restrain her I don't know
about beating oh you're so sensible I
think you first have to look around and
see where the CCTV is I like I think if
a girl starts getting Reckless I think
you're allowed to like [__] nipple
twist them as hard as you can
get a pillow and then sock him through
the pillow
it's like a silencer basically it's a
silencer I think what you're allowed to
do is get the the restaurant yeah and
[__] push that [__] interface oh you
can you can mush you can mush the face
for sure a stiff arm is good he has a
pillow you're a woman I respect that
anybody have a pillow I'll use a neck
pillow because there's a hole in it
that dude that's a lot and it's just
collateral damage right that's wild dude
those are those are probably my two best
stories that happened so [__] fast
dude it was crazy she probably knows who
you are now though for sure probably now
yeah do you think she was so drunk she
just didn't even know everybody acts
like she don't remember it she probably
does it she was she was drunk like
really drunk like I'm talking about like
you know like still all over the I'm
surprised she was able to land that hit
yeah that's crazy it was crazy cheese I
was kind of like black right here for
like a week yeah it was a [__] hard
slap wow and she does not fight she
might talk that [__] but oh she's not
trying to fight nobody
holy [__] yeah damn I want a [__]
Port poked her with some Chopsticks
throw some shark fin soup better yeah
you know put a lettuce wrap on her head
throw a piece of orange chicken just do
all these comical attacks naming
Everything Home Alone attacks walnut
shrimp in her eyes I know dude just some
hot tea hot tea on the face dude heat up
the doorknob so when she leaves it burns
her hands
I would have got that bright red sauce
that they use for the wonton crisp for
the appetizers yeah
any other Foods you want to add Ryan
tom yum soup that's time
[Music]